hi I'm Erik Bosse in a trailer for the
upcoming movie glass was released at
comic-con
glass is the third installment of the M
night Shyamalan superhero series
following unbreakable and split a movie
that we win him to having no idea was an
unbreakable sequel until Bruce Willis
showed up in the final scene and
launched the M night Shyamalan injures
glass of course focuses on Elijah price
aka mr. glass the mentor turned villain
mastermind and unbreakable
so that Sam Jackson can now be part of
three superhero movie universes so let's
break down this trailer frame by frame
for all the details that you might have
missed and of course spoiler warning in
case any of my predictions end up being
right let's get started it's amazing to
meet you it is simply extraordinary my
name is dr. Ellie staple and I'm a
psychiatrist my work concerns a
particular type of delusion of grandeur
okay these opening shots introduce us to
Sarah paulsen as dr. Ellie staple a
psychiatrist who studies delusions of
grandeur with his movies and night
Shyamalan contextualizes superhuman
abilities in the world of academia in
psychology even The Sixth Sense started
out as sort of a psychological horror
movie where without scene the marketing
for it you definitely would have seen
Cole's ability to see ghosts as
initially framed as a kind of delusion
of grandeur that Malcolm believes is
just in the boys head until of course
the movie reveals physical evidence the
visions are real split included many
scenes with Kevin Krum psychiatrist dr.
Fletcher discussing hotly debated topics
of mental health regarding physiological
manifestations of mental conditions and
with dr. Ellie staple glass continues to
stay within the rules of this world
where unlike the Marvel Cinematic
Universe of the DC expanded universe in
movies the belief in the existence of
superpowers isn't fully given yet there
may also be some significance to shamans
character named choices like I always
thought Kevin crumb was fitting
considering his split personalities a
chrome being a part of a whole there
could also be something with David Dunn
and Elijah price done suggesting
completion like the guy who finishes a
fight and price implying a cost like the
price of being a superhero is that there
is an equal and opposite supervillain
somewhere in the world that you have to
fight so staple could refer to Ellie's
clerical function or rather her role in
bringing elements together or am I
reading too much into it shut up let's
move on
it's a growing field I specialize in
those individuals who believe they are
superheroes good for you okay here we
see various shots of the mental
institution and notice the set design
the cells all have three windows
paralleling the three primary characters
of the story
Kevin cell has these charges to keep him
from getting too close to the door he
can actually see caution tape on the
ground to warn him from getting too
close and we see the three amigos
Elijah price aka mr. glass Sam Jackson
Kevin Crowe make a 24 different
personalities in this human's head
including the Beast and they're all
known collectively as the horde and
they're all played by James McAvoy and
David duck Bruce Willis notice ow
unlike the others David has chained to a
metal plate bolted to the floor so even
though they think his superpowers are
really just in his head
apparently they definitely fear that
super strength enough to bolt him down
really the overall production design
here is really well done again three
shapes show up with the windows and
their reflections on the floor in the
whole room is this pastel purple color
each of these characters is defined by a
distinct color which we saw them
highlighted in in that poster that was
just released
David the hero is green he's seen in
this faded green clothes here and that
dark green coat that he wears outside
Kevin's color is yellow / orange it's a
fiery animalistic tone for his
connection to the Beast and Elijah wears
purple his blanket here and his mr.
glass suit the fact that this whole room
is purple suggests that while the story
is about three different figures they're
all in the world of mr. glass let's move
on the three of you have convinced
yourselves you have extraordinary gifts
like something out of a comic book
David Dunn the only person to survive
that trainwreck all those years ago we
see some shots of this comic book store
which blends the green and purple color
tones reflecting the duality between
David and Elijah it's also a close-up
shot of one of these comic books now
this isn't any Marvel or DC comic that I
recognize it was probably created
originally for this movie actually if
you look closely there's a beastly
character doing a lot of the same moves
that we saw the beasts do and split
including bending prison bars perhaps
someone has made a comic that
fictionalized real news events allow you
to actually explain this exact theory
about comics in the movie unbreakable I
believe comics are form of history that
someone somewhere felt or experienced
then of course those experiences and
that history got chewed up in the
commercial machine got jazzed up made
titillating cartooned for the sale rack
we also see a quick flashback with
someone reusing footage from unbreakable
with David on the train that crashed
that was one that left him as the sole
survivor and made him aware of his
powers let's move on what do you do I'm
in security do you think you have
superpowers
it's a feeling vision I have to touch
them you believe you are a protector so
David says he works in security now and
we see what that security means he just
kind of roughs people up suggesting he's
continuing his vigilante work I noticed
how that kid he supposedly saven appears
to be watching a video of some other
Street conflict that could be showing
David or Kevin even in action we also
see David on the street bumping into
people and remember an unbreakable it
was established that in addition to his
strength and durability he can see
visions of the bad things people have
done by just making physical contact
with them so here when he bumps into
Kevin Crum we see the quick shots of
kidnapped cheerleaders and notice that
David is also listening to headphones
perhaps he has like a mobile police
scanner to tune in to crime reports as
they come in moving on to the next
section my name is Patricia
I have no question there are two dozen
identities I'm Mary Reynolds we almost
got to broke that live in that body with
you it'd be it's common any minute now
for you guys okay this section focuses
on Kevin's character actually shows a
few different personalities that we saw
in split starting with Patricia she's
the calm older woman that many of the
others listen to there's also Mary
Reynolds an Irish woman someone speaking
in Spanish this could be Norma or
Felicia and a stereotypical bro
apparently we will see 21 of his 24
identities in this movie actually like
the detail that all of them demand their
own toothbrushes we also see Kevin as
his head wig identity the child to be
wears rollerskates as he warns the
cheerleaders about the Beast
by the way kidnapped cheerleaders still
in their uniforms pretty on the nose
comic book stereotypical dilemma it
reminds me a lot of the show heroes from
her save the cheerleader save the world
and for kidnapped teenage girls is one
step up from the three that were
kidnapped and split assign that Kevin or
the dangerous identity Dennis and of
course the beasts are escalating their
violence on to the next section but what
I am questioning is your belief that you
are something more than human and yet it
is true okay two things to point out in
this part one James jacked a boy damn
last year there was some rumors that
McAvoy actually ate 6,000 calories a day
to gain this weight but he denied the
rumors he didn't go that crazy just
fifty nine hundred but his strict
workout regimen did emphasize his traps
like no sell results of this body shape
that Hulk's out his presents on screen
from the chest stuck especially when
he's like heaving like an animal
absolutely this little smile that Elijah
gives that the idea being quote more
than human-like remember he doesn't have
a real physical superpower like the
other two it's more of a super weakness
with extremely brittle bones really it's
his advanced mind in his head and his
inflated ego that makes him more than
human in the same way that these other
two are moving on my own break easily
I've had 94 breaks in my life but you
have an extraordinary thank you
this is not a cartoon this is the real
world no way okay there's a quick shot
of a shadow cast from what looks like
Elijah's wheelchair suggesting his
escape from its mental institution we
also see Elijah macGruber in together
there's some kind of Linz device from
scavenged parts and you could see
security monitors behind him
maybe he's broken apart some kind of
security camera needs changing the
angles to hide his escape wait a guy to
mental institution should not be in a
place with her security monitors there's
also Casey cook played by Anya Taylor
joy she's the one captive to escape
Kevin that we saw in split and it looks
like dr. staples bringing her in to
visit with kevin has someone who may be
able to break through with him or maybe
keep the beast at bay kind of like Black
Widow and Hulk Suns getting real low big
guy moving on and yet some of us still
don't die with bullets
some of us can still bend steel okay few
shots in this section to point out we
see what looks like the Horde surrender
in arrest split left him at large in the
world remember we also see some more
shots of David unfurling his hooded coat
and plunging into a pool of water
remember his weakness is water and
fighting with some riot police
apparently shoving them into a big train
car and bending a steel rod to trap them
in interesting detail here notice how
David has laid some planks on the muddy
ground to walk on I guess the ground is
pretty wet here so he's trying to avoid
the moisture from getting into his feet
come on Davey ever heard of galoshes
duck weeders and before we move on we
see Casey joined by Joseph Dunn that was
David's son and Elijah's mother mrs.
price with the same actor Spencer treat
Clark and Charlayne Woodard returning
from unbreakable kinda looks like stable
brought in someone important to each of
the three to see how they would react
moving on I've been waiting for world to
see that big man meet the Beast okay in
this section we see someone in the comic
book store that we saw before with the
green and purple color tones there is a
hero's and a villains section and among
the heroes racks you can see x-men
spider-man Hulk Superman and the flash
all grouped together really mixing the
colors of the Marvel and DC laundry
they're normally comic book shops aren't
categorized by heroes and villains since
you know there would be way more comics
for Heroes but maybe this shop could
have been like patron by Elijah and he
insisted on a robust collection of
villains comics since those are the
stories that he identifies with and
notice how the heroes section is lit in
green corresponding to David and the
villains section is lit in purple to
Elijah another nice touch and Elijah
meets the Beast who gives him this long
sniff like a wild animal getting
acquainted with another deciding whether
it can trust the stranger let's move on
I have for your sake that he likes you
that sounds like the bad guys teaming up
a lot of people are going to die don't
do this okay in this section live does
bad guys teaming up line is interesting
it sounds like as if glass will feature
Elijah and David struggling to control
the Horde the Beast which could be why
Kevin is so often depicted in the center
between the villain in the hero there's
a quick shot of nurses running away from
David this will be part of his escape
from the mental institution and this
creepy shot of the Beast crawling on the
ceiling pipes toward David as it tries
to rescue the cheerleaders reminds me a
lot of that famous shot in aliens when
the beastly Xenomorphs crawl toward them
above the ceiling hanging upside down
moving on you ready
few things here first we get a close-up
of dr. staple pulling someone out of the
water she could be saving David here
probably after the Beast launched him
into that tank and tried to drown him
notice this shot of David roaring I like
how they included the red marks from the
two gunshot wounds from when KC fired
the shotgun Adam and split remember
those blasts did not bring him down but
he still has a scars woman there's also
a quick shot of the Beast galloping like
a cheetah you actually see Elijah in the
background with him perhaps trying to
tame the Beast and get him under his
control and on to the last parts what do
we call you sir first name mr. last name
okay no one's first name is mr. I
thought we learned this lesson in dr.
strange
oh no have you been that come atashi mr.
dr. mr. dr. it's strange but I guess
that's the point with mr. glass Elijah
price is redefining himself here mr.
glass was the nickname his childhood
bullies gave him and now he's owning it
so that going forward he will only be
known as mr. glass and as we wait for
this movie to premiere in January 2019 a
question I'll leave you guys with should
the unbreakable cinematic universe
expand beyond this like how deep should
this rabbit all go should mr. glass next
try to recruit the boy you can see
ghosts or the trees that confuse Mark
Wahlberg okay I've already turned myself
off of this comment down below with your
thoughts or tweet me directly idea vas
and following new rock stars on Twitter
for updates on our videos like this
video share it around and subscribe to
new rock stars look we know there's a
lot that came out at Comic Con so be on
the lookout for our trailer breakdowns
for Aquaman and Shazam Godzilla the king
of monsters phantom ask peeps and the
Rick Grimes of tender wold
that's what it's called right thanks for
watching
[Music]